[Musique]
déjà près de la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux paix
johnny c'est aussi le plus sérieux à
jouer il s'est mis debout droit au
public un ami
[Musique]
bonjour oui bonjour tout cas encore
bonjour ça va oui non bah ça va ou est
ce que tu sais je suis venu la
catastrophe parce que le dessinateur
peintre qui m'a appris au saut du ni oui
m'a glissé soul elle trois dessins oui
et puis ben j'arrive je les ai même pas
regardé un je ne sais pas alors je vais
pas d'un grand secours
tu m'as l'air un petit peu petit peu
raplapla quand même pas du tout pas du
tout pas du tout un bon alors j'ai le
droit des saints bon alors il ya trois
dessins tu connais oui je rappelle le
système il suffit en fait si j'ai bien
compris de suivre l'ordre logique de
l'évolution de la situation dans les
dessins j'ai l'ordre chronologique
l'ordre logique visa ya des indices bien
précises ya des indices précis si on les
regarde bien on doit se rendre compte
qu'il faut placer tel dessin avant
l'autre etc etc
alors on regarde le premier alors
regardons le carroi paulissen ça c'est
pour qu'est ce que c'est que ça c'est
une route ça c'est une route c'est un
chat c'est à dessein tête un dessin oui
c'est une scène champêtre attends je
vais mal à nous trois nous ment parce
que tu comprendrais peut-être mieux tu
vois il ya des petites indications
peut-être un bas
c'était en août oui bah ça oui la route
nous sommes d'accord il ya toujours une
espèce de chant oui je suis une grande
fleur la wii dans le troisième le
troisième ça s'est passé la même c'est
là bien escargots un escargot m'enfin
c'est la même c'est le même paysage à
peu de choses près alors quand même si
il ya quelque chose près dont je crois
que j'ai trouvé attendre oui aussi nous
sommes dans notre hémisphère c'est à
dire la moitié nord de la terre n'est ce
parent l'hémisphère de paris oui au sort
comme son adjoint alors regarde bien
en principe je vois une ombre portée -
ici alors je mettrais pourrait les
porter bah elle est portée par sa
feignante le sacco l'oeil le soleil à ce
moment là si on était très tôt le matin
ça dont environ 6 heures du matin moi je
dirais que ça c'est le ça ça va être le
premier dessin ça moi je le mettrais
comme ça moi c'est ça ouais alors fait
le second à ton avis alors le second le
second si on admet que le soleil tourne
dans le sens habituel tout de même ça
devrait être un petit peu plus tard
l'ombre est là un petit peu plus tard tu
voyais
et puis enfin on arriverait vers le
milieu de la journée midi peu près avec
une ombre où ça devrait être meilleure
si l'idée l'ombre totalement droite par
rapport à la fleur et le coup de bambou
là c'est le séduira voilà est-ce que
j'ai gagné tu as rien gagner tu actuelle
a juste le droit de sortir quoi ça au
jardin petit bas alors on va n'y a pas
d'autre explication est donné bon bah
alors tout va tuer des seuils de me
faire prendre pour ce que je ne suis pas
fait venir pour h&m
alors va y réfléchir dans le jardin
votera bien j'ai compris qu'est ce que
c'est que ça enfin de hockey alors moi
dès qu'est ce que je vais faire pour que
je me tue pas tant du poète comme il est
dit dans ce qu'est ce que vous faites là
tous les deux mais bien on est en train
de pousser mes études après été simple à
faire comme j'ai pas été chez line on
regarde tu étais moi c'est naturel moi
c'est naturel au aloha on l'appelle mais
aussi celles fabrice c'est toi qui m'a
appelé fibra
tu m'appeler moi qui bravent fondé de
fourche et au dec à jour au le coup tu
entends tient à ce n'est qu'un couteau
tu en voilà la cour lui il pas c'est
bien pour lui
non pas le coup norway quoi le coin le
coma
c'est pourquoi dans le jeu du point
commun alors je vous rappelle comment
les choses se passent encore une fois
ils vont tous les trois représenter
quelque chose et nous devrons découvert
ensemble quel est le point qu'ils ont en
commun qui commence c'est toi résistive
mois récents
oui alors tu sais je suis pas mécontent
la de ce qu'on a trouvé
alors aujourd'hui moi je suis je suis un
cheval je sais pas moi superbe alezan tu
connais oui c'est très ne connaît pas
ses chevaux qu'on écrit nir presque
blonde le comme les cheveux de bell bell
tu vois oui alors oui je me sens capable
d'enlever d'ailleurs des épreuves
prestigieuses et aussi tu savais comme
c'est agréable d'être soigné des débits
chenille comme je le suis mais pour
morgane café dur je dois t'avouer que je
peux aussi être un bon et solide cheval
de ferme qu'on envoie sur les routes ou
dans les dans les champs par tous les
temps je peux faire tous les travaux ce
qui est bien commode quand on un
tracteur en panne
c'était ça c'était ma démonstration oui
c'était toi ça bon alors belle belle ma
fierté bien mais moi c'est mieux
puisque nous parlons de la campagne des
travaux de la ferme restons dans le même
endroit pour toi fabrice je vais me
déguiser un paysage non personne
adorable
seulement je suis obligé ni lever tous
les matins pour aller donner à manger à
mes bêtes ou pour aller traire mes
vaches est beau aussi comme le cheval du
tout quand j'y vais par tous les temps
qu'il pleuve qu'il vente qu'il fasse
très froid ou très chaud je suis
toujours dehors
as tu sais à la campagne est toujours
quelque chose à faire
un petit détail je me sens spécialement
à mon aise dans les fermes hollandaise
au old days
oui oui oui la série j'ai compris
oui oui oui ça je crois que je suis sur
une piste ma faim je suis pas sûr de moi
aussi je vais attendre la version de
pousse pousse et ben moi je suis je suis
une automobile oui une automobile qui a
bien des malheurs figure toi tu mon
propriétaire est un monsieur très occupé
toujours pressé un peu distrait alors
souvent bien il me laisse n'importe où
devant une porte cochère sur un passage
clouté en double file
tiens et même devant une caserne de
pompiers rencontre alors en ce moment en
ce moment tu sais où je suis sur un
trottoir carrément sur un trottoir alors
je suis très embêté parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont venus me voir
et puis m'ont fait de drôles de choses
et ça ça me fait un peu mal mais j'ai un
peu mal à la roue avant tu vois il ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'on vienne me
chercher d'ici quelques temps pour me
conduire à la fourrière
si jamais c'était sacré il en fera une
tête mon patron en voilà c'est tout et
vous croyez que vous allez me voyez nous
allons coller avec sa villa il va pas
trouver
vous croyez que vous allez nous coller
ils ont tous déjà trouvé tous à bonjour
à risque au volet et ben non c'est pas
la peine de le dire pour vérifier mais
tout con quand est un cheval ou un
cheval comme une jolie fermière landaise
oui et comme les voitures mal garées
porte des sabots
il alla c'était difficile pour tous nos
déficits et traiterez c'est le fameux
sabots de denver que l'on met sur les
roues des automobiles qui sont mal
garées pour les immobiliser voilà on ne
peut pas marcher avait assez distant
nuit tu t'y connais rien j'ai gagné toi
nous conduit comme un sabot les
secousses bout 6-3
je l'allumé raymond petit jeu musical
fabrice monti chouette est alerte et
bisous à toi mon petit con quand je
jouais fabrice alors on va jouer
ensemble bonjour joue on joue attaquant
petits crayons stylos
il a tout prévu il a joué prévu il est
formidable bon alors tu vas au tableau
et si tu écris un mot en huit lettres
rouges maintenant on attaque est pas là
j'ai première lettre alors la première
l'aide c'est un as
oui la dernière c1 r
il a fait oui oui à huile est en fait si
la mère est la dernière un air comme
rené à la balle alors vous imaginez bien
entendu qu'ils ont encore non je ne sais
quelle erreur
il ya un souci ne s'est toujours pas
écrire sans fautes d'orthographe non
c'est même plus la peine d'espérer quoi
que ce soit non mais là on va essayer de
se débrouiller avec ce que nous appelons
on peut alors animal un haut bas oui oh
bah alors tu es formidable c'est un
animal qui rampent anneaux et rend pas
qu'à des pâtes
il a des pattes insectes à huy aux
favoris nous avons tous quand c'est un
insecte 1 d'après toi
non non non maintenant que j'y suis non
non non je dis moi j'en vois souvent
mais tu sais ils sont gentils avec moi
elles sont gentils avec moi celle sont
gentils
bah oui ça me fait ça te fait peur toi
oui
ah ben ça fait peur vous êtes sûr aussi
mal insectes non ces prêts à passer tous
les deux vous êtes vraiment bien calé un
départ en tout cas je peux te dire que
ça allait donner une lettre je vais
quand même te donner la cinquième l'aide
par il faut que tu devines quand même
c'est vrai qu'il devine tout mon frère
cinquième set
une bête tout noir ah oui oui c'est une
belle tenue moi je crois que j'ai une
idée des plus sur la lettre la c1 j en
battant
et c est là mais tu la mets août à
lettres un tu l'avais août on amène à
voir comment la lettre o n
non c g que tu m'a dit ah bah cgg parce
que moi je crois que je sais elle
cinquième l'aide c'est un j c'est pas la
peine d'aller plus loin te fatigue pas à
mon avis cette araignée et ben si un
règne encore trouvé et hummer à la fin
dernier oui quand vous le voyez il
progresse nettement à ériger sa filiale
algérienne alors pour les gens civilisés
voilà comment on écrit a régné à rai1 g
n et michard signé deux et on a fini bon
bah d'accord inégal belinga l'on peut se
faire repérer
alors d'accord d'accord moi je l'écrirai
comme ça plus mais dis-moi fabriqué moi
est ce que tu sais ce que j'arrive à
faire les araignées avec leur toile et
non seulement elles s'en servent comme
piège pour attraper les mouches mais il
y en a qui fabrique une espèce de
maisons maisons bien fermé tellement
bien fermé qu'avec ça elles peuvent
descendre au fond de l'eau à qui ce
n'est pas fan une véritable cloche à
plongeurs d'indiens mois cet été je vais
m'installer au bord de l'eau et je vais
regarder les araignées et tous les
autres bêtes d'ailleurs toutes les
autres vues et si on sait bien observer
on en apprend des choses à part leur
s'aggrave bien sûr mes enfants je crois
qu'il faut aller voir ces labels est
enlevé le bris
[Musique]
la fabrique bien jouer avec moi
n'hésitez pas à ce que toi tu es
maintenant chers fabry oui bah la
dernière fois nous nous sommes bien sûr
j'étais fâché oui mais moi j'ai déjà
oublié
oui et toi tu ne fais pas un petit
sourire et je te faire des heureux mais
je ne veux pas que ce soit trop
difficile
alors c'est très facile via gitans mais
nos jardins j'ai beaucoup de choses à
faire
si tu voulais mais dès ce serait très
gentil tu veux bien mais je veux bien
on rassure toi je vais te confier des
travaux très simple d'abord il ya des
fusées qui ont poussé n'importe comment
lier les branches qui dépasse
franchement c'est très laid il faut
couper ça avec une high as oui oui oui
avec une si zot y compris mais ça vient
quand tu auras fini tu seras gentil
j'aimerais que tu me cueille un gros
bouquet dédié à louis
un gros bouquet de lilas c'est ce alors
qu'ils mettraient dans l'entrée j'ai
besoin d'un peu de décoration pour la
petite fait que je vais donner demain au
gésu god save et reggae ce serait de
dire une petite fête très liane en liane
à sa femme on mit media lab a bola et
comme je suis sûr que tu vas prendre
beaucoup de plaisir à travailler dans ce
jardin on est au calme on respire bien
c'est excellent pour la santé
je ne confierai un autre travail est ce
que comme cueillir aussi un petit
bouquet de mozac timoré de mozart oui un
petit bouquet de mimosas de moi j'ai cru
que tu parlais de la mozzarella moi je
sais je ne pense que aux pizzas alors du
mail and de mimosas se sent bon ensuite
nous passerons un travail plus délicat
est on venu que j'ai envie d'avoir de
très belles fleurs cet été tu sais
apprécier serait temps de s'occuper
d'eux mais ceux notés quoi demi-soeur
doter ce tas plusieurs ça wily 10e puis
avec un petit mot derrière je croyais
que tu me parlais de thé
soeur mais non de thé ce2 têtus parlent
déjà de thé mais de thé semi voilà je
veux déranger bien droit qu'il faut que
ce soit tiré au corps au rebond alors là
facile
bordeaux bordeaux c'est concerne les
graines je voudrais que tu choisisses
des espèces très décoratives ne prend
pas des graines de tourner en rond on
tourne autour de tournesol et parce que
c'est encombrant oui la petite auberge y
penses tu as l'air d'avoir de la bonne
volonté que prendra de la ccid et tuant
pulvérisera sur le gazon je remarquais
qu'il y avait plein de nids de four
alors là de faux de faux mais des nids
de fourmis
c'est parfait mon petit fabrice bailly
ça suffira pour usure de bravo j'ai bien
travaillé
oh oui c'était 00h tu m'as tu vu j'ai
employé depuis 10 ans oui c'est vrai
mais mis mon dieu je n'y avais pas pensé
on chante immédiatement pour se séparer
à tout les quatre amis des jardins et
d'amis du cac
biron qui me plaît que la vie majeur
désiste et j'ai shop se déchausse les
comme juni pas de mine war lèveront à
faire attention les quatre amis sont
descendus dit les quatre ça ni sont
heureux car ils aiment la vie
oui
m
[Musique]
j'habite pas jouer entre amis vouloir
devenir amis
[Musique]